Ok. Je rentre  dans le système, et ... Bingo !
Qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?!
Euh, ça rame. T'es marrant toi ! ça rame.
*Ordinateur: La base de signatures de virus à été…*           -Chhhut Chhut !
Ça va, ça va. Tu te souviens quand tu m'apprenais à tirer à l'arc ? Quand on était petits…
T'étais trop mauvais….
Tu te souviens quand on était petits et qu'on jouait à l'arc tous les deux...
Mais ta gueule ! Casse-toi !
Va chercher du monde !!
Game on.
Ben nan tu sais pas coudre ! Connard.
Attendez, zoomez dans ses lunettes.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?!
Oh mon dieu !
Zoomez sur ses lunettes.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est un pixel noir, monsieur ...
C'est parce que j'ai une résolution de merde en fait, alors ...
Du coup on voit rien ...
Passez-moi votre épingle à cheveux !
C'est bon !
On est...on est à l'intérieur, on est trois !
Partez sans moi...
J'vais vous ralentir.
Who ho ! Vous faites quoi là ?!
Me...me laissez pas là !
Mais portez-moi ! Je peux...je peux peut-être marcher !
Nan !